hurricane Fiona Bears down on Turks and
Caicos Islands making landfall as a
powerful Category 3 storm threatening to
devastate the tiny Caribbean archipelago
in the Dominican Republic crops have
been destroyed and houses damaged by the
first major hurricane of the Atlantic
season
all this area does farming and it
depends on production on the crops and
everything was destroyed there was
nothing left a lot of people had loans
to grow bananas coffee cocoa everything
is gone
hundreds were forced from their homes by
widespread flooding in Puerto Rico among
them adalberto Rios and his daughter
Martha who are now staying at a shelter
with other displaced people
my faith is strong and I know God will
help me I lost everything but if God
took everything away it's only because
here's something better planned for me
in the wake of the storm U.S federal
officials have promised to increase Aid
and support to Puerto Rico
hundreds of FEMA and federal responders
are on the ground in Puerto Rico
including U.S Army Corps of engineer
power restoration experts and urban
search and rescue teams heavy rains from
Fiona caused flooding across the U.S
island territory leading to damaged
roads and collapsed Bridges
here in southern Puerto Rico tens of
thousands of residents are depending on
construction Crews like this one to
restore running water to just some of
the community's worst affected by
Hurricane Fiona
the U.S National Hurricane Center is
warning Fiona will continue to gain
strength over the coming days Manuel
rapalo Al Jazeera San Juan Puerto Rico